okay this pretty girl look at this
pretty girl over here
that's Samantha that's Brandi yeah hey
guys and this is the real rejects well
Ryan's not here because he's already
seen this trailer today what we're going
to be reviewing is get hard is always
good right yeah it was super sexy and we
made a funny right you're laughing
already right okay I maybe we should
just watch this I think we should sorry
yeah sorry
we tried we're really trying once you
step through this threshold is deep
[Music]
I'm sorry
did you make dickade decade doesn't
sound like a significant improvement
over dick but awesome and very funny and
the second trailer so I saw the first
one and I reacted it to it with Ryan and
this one it has a lot more jokes and
stuff but it still has the one with the
girl she's know in a few bad dog phases
yeah II like vocalize to it oh I think
it's fun to see Will Ferrell in this
like professional role because I don't
think I mean I don't think I've seen him
in such a professional like a human
would be guy oh but he was in the movie
where he played the politician of the
campaign I mean wasn't he in the
campaign was it okay yeah so using the
campaign okay and professional I guess
that's my fault for messing with that's
okay yeah either way still it looks
pretty entertaining this you will
ferrell and this kind of role yeah I
mean with Kevin Hart and Kevin I still
think the height difference is really
funny just in and of itself how
different I think it's really really
that's the tall guy who you think would
be intimidating is actually the wimpy
sad dog in face like curly and I would
be hard though they have really good
chemistry between the two of them to say
we do they complement one another in
that respect
yeah they definitely bounce off of each
other well and yeah there's some funny
moments happening I can't wait to see
the full thing
yeah me too I'm super excited we laugh
the way we're hoping to make other
people laugh with our little and I don't
know if it's kind of a thing that's
gonna I don't think it works yeah sorry
it we tried with that we really did we
wouldn't try thank you for watching
please subscribe to the real rejects
it's awesome
you know and Sam Samantha's channel yeah
do that cuz that might be cool and
Danny's channel cuz you know she's a
badass and she's even better than s know
I'm getting art in the corner so you
have to subscribe to him
well you can't click his dick right now
but he'd like you to thanks just think
about it yeah I just think about his
dick I like thinking about my dear how
did somebody does
so what we're reviewing today is yo you
totally ruined it so today what we're
going to review is it's hard I think I'm
gonna do that again